I've had Island for about two and a half
months now I would say that this is the
most advanced multi reticulan hand there
it's when you see me open and close the
hand you'll actually see the fingers
curling actually grasping the item that
I'm holding on to my name is Tom
Schneider and I lost my hand
wakeboarding back in 2006 I went to pass
to handle behind my back and as soon as
I did there was just a little bit of
slack in the rope so I thought I just
missed the handle completely next thing
I know they had the handle wraps around
one time and it didn't even sit on this
but unfortunately it was a blood clot
day ended up causing the blood flow to
stops in my hands a business development
manager for advanced time dynamics since
I'm an amputee myself my personal
knowledge with prosthetics everything
like that plays a huge part with talking
to patients from the day I became an AP
teacher looking at prosthetics they have
changed immensely to this day and it's
only been eight years now so it went
from just being able to open and close
and very mechanically not a large
opening or anything like that to where
right now it's got six motors in it so
the thumb will actually move into
different positions all the fingers move
so this is the more advanced ones out as
soon as you open an app up and it syncs
with the hand inside that app it has all
these different pictures of different
grips so I can just click on
those pictures it'll move the hand into
that position and then I can open and
close from there
in public I mean I get kids come with me
all the time that's if I'm Iron Man if
I'm Batman
like if you look kind of up and say I
was so cool there's been making my life
easier for the database that when I walk
my dog to a coffee shop
I can hold my dog in one hand and hold
whatever I get in the other it's things
like walking out to an ATM being able to
pull out my wall and hold my wallet put
the card in and be able to use the
touchscreen on it as these really simple
things that like when you hear about I'm
like oh anyone can do that but not only
a PT's can